[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
quiero que me ayuden a levantar la mano
cuántos seres que estamos aquí el
trabajo marketing
sus ventas
somos
la izquierda y creo de la experta en
marketing vienen recuerdos superbikes y
juegos
estimula a una persona convencerle
el software stop posteriormente cuando
fui creciendo fue tangibilizar nuestra
parte y pues descubrió luego son muy
rentables en la secundaria
hemos compañeros porque porque la
mayoría
y todos
y creciendo mucho
que fuera
y yo
y una cocina y mucha gente alrededor de
cinco o diez minutos
y más
derecho
[Música]
estudié marketing
y ahí me di cuenta
era mi vocación tender cobijas
es el objetivo de cualquier empresa de
cualquier objetivo económico
sin embargo
sus usuarios originales estas personas
que al final son los compradores y
adivinas lindos y necesidades no los
tragantes y las empresas no toman en
consideración
las personas
actualmente las marcas las empresas
investigación e investigaciones
de valor
entender y saber desde qué dispositivo
[Música]
soltero
todo eso es importante porque porque nos
brinda y nos brindan esa parte
de conocerlos para crear contenido de
valor que después se convierta en una
venta
antes las empresas
de 16 años tienen explicación que
realizaban cada una de las fases está
inmersa la persona sub comprado el
objetivo innovar paso en falso sin antes
investigar pero actualmente estamos
estamos en punto de ese consumismo que
hemos perdido esa sensibilidad que el
contacto humano que actualmente las
empresas nuevas lanzan productos lastran
servicios sin antes estar en la cocina
que se están cristianos
muchas veces que me ha tocado por
ejemplo casos con con tintes
[Música]
y en todas las redes
están en las redes sociales siempre y
cuando en esa red social o en este canal
de comunicación si el público
porque realmente si no lo que hacemos es
ese bombardeo de información realmente
relevante los usuarios o los usuarios
que están en mensaje de este caso la
publicidad que no va dirigida para ellos
o contenido que es bueno o atractivo
entonces realmente es como una
valoración
el pensar si lo que es plácido está
generando un embargo el impacto es
positivo o tiene un objetivo porque si
no la tiene pues la verdad no ha tenido
el caso hacerlo mejor hacer otro tipo de
actividades actuaciones donde realmente
se encuentre su público objetivo
y el mundo luciana es la empatía es
empatía que les decía que actualmente en
este mundo digital en este mundo
globalizado se está perdiendo esa parte
de contacto físico muchas veces ni
siquiera nos ponemos a pensar si es algo
o nuestra publicidad va enfocada a la
necesidad a las personas
todos tenemos problemáticas todos
tenemos necesidades como crisis es
principalmente el contenido / orientado
a esa parte para que a partir de empatía
que muchas veces recomiendo es pasarlo
por un lado presionar
[Música]
porque una de las empresas
ellos está presente actualmente en
generar publicidad o generamos
simplemente mensajes de ventas pues
realmente esa parte es crucial porque
cuando las empresas se presentan pues
mundiales
la mejor opción
presencia de un camino recorrido un
camino donde los otros en mercadotecnia
llamamos que es una metodología tiempo
marketing 2000 kilos clic con nuestro
usuario antes de decirme cómprame yate
si no sabes que tú tienes esta
problemática a la mejor ésta tienes
estas opciones para sí mismas
necesidad de la última opción es la
parte que el producto o servicio está
apareciendo
[Música]
sin embargo una persona
y esto
[Música]
observó
las grandes pierden esa sensibilidad
y finalmente con la parte de consumismo
que les hablaba en las empresas
activamente se están enfocando a generar
ventas pierdes la parte de poder generar
como estrategias de landa
es muy importante porque sus bienes sólo
queda la comunicación de boca y genera
realmente una menuda no te lleva
calculado y se ha generado una
transacción se da o bien por un producto
o servicio y hasta el pueblo que te va a
dar esa parte de marca y de
posicionamiento es el área fidelización
de clientes que tus clientes que quieran
que tus clientes te digan
sobre la competencia no sé ustedes saben
está piense de manera interna en una
marca puede ser una más para los hombres
pero es la marca
en esa parte cada vez que los anuncios
lo que yo vengo a transmitir a todas
esas marcas a sus negocios es que deben
de lograr
[Música]
la parte bosch y crearé cuando una
empresa una pyme un negocio lo que tenga
lo logra ya están del otro lado
los clientes de publicidad
por qué
[Música]
y bueno como conclusión la izquierda de
cuarteles puntos
el primer punto bajo muy enfocado a
ellas personas
[Música]
un escritor y el marketing los usuarios
en hacer un estudio etnográfico y
animarse a su cultura
punto número 2
la verdad es que no me haciendo otra
cosa
y el punto número 3
[Música]
es materialmente más no es poner precios
está poner valor a las cosas
ruiz investigar los mercados
no puede vender mucho es enamorar no es
promocionar esa publicidad es
creatividad
[Aplausos]